you should play chess with Checkers
pieces I like that idea actually I
haven't done that in a while board theme
no peace
theme
okay good luck to my opponent so this
looks like Checkers but it's still chess
the pieces are just all circles and I
have to keep track of what's what so
let's play a Lon I don't know who I'm
playing so there will be a few
challenges
first to hopefully play a full game
keeping track of everything and also to
guess my opponent's
[Music]
rating and good luck to everyone being
able to keep track of where things
are I mean this might be like a useful
visualization type
exercise kind of a stepping stone
between normal chest and blindfold
chest I mean so far it's not too
difficult H5 is a little bit
random but I don't get the move list
either
so like I can't really go back and
notation to see what's
where I still have my uh my London setup
it helps to like kind of know the
structure
oh yes my
circles do people enjoy watching this
like how many people watching are
already kind of lost of what's
where I do have a lot of circles
[Music]
everywhere
I'm 100% lost but I still enjoy it okay
that's what I like to hear so here
there's a tactic because I have Circle
take Circle and then I use my other
Circle to attack this
circle and this looks like a looks like
a knight but it's actually a
queen actually is just looks like a
circle so this is a knight attack
in the two
circles a nice
position who would be winning If This
Were If This Were
go I wouldn't I like be trapping this
Pawn or this uh
[Music]
Circle I kind of forget the rules of Go
I learned a few years ago
okay oh that's a
knight so the queen attacks my circle
but I have this winning Connect
Four actually winning connect
five can I get connect
six
let's take
this actually do I need to take
that I'll take
this and then take
this and then
this so it simplified a little bit this
is actually easier to keep track of now
cuz it's Queen and Bishop Queen and
Knight Rooks are still in the
[Music]
corners and everything else are pawns
except this is my
king oh there's a funny tactic coming
up involves this circle and this circle
against these
circles
oh no my
[Music]
circle someone call
um what's the right
word someone call a protractor
no someone call a square someone call a
triangle okay let's play this
move someone call a
compass okay so this circle is attacking
this circle this circle but also
this oh this circle is glowing
red
okay
check still not simple
check
heart thanks for the
heart
wow Circle take
Circle unleashing this
[Music]
circle and now where's the
checkmates check there
check
check check
chuck
chuck get ready for
it okay I have to pin
this get ready for
it don't flag Don't
flag
check look at look at my circles about
to Castle
checkmat okay I got the castle
mate it looks so pretty the circle
glowing
red can I switch this backy new year oh
I forgot to
streamer my wife approves of me watching
on account of your soothing voice oh
that's nice shout out to your wife thank
you John
Brown how can we appreciate this beauty
and escape the circles op P set and then
this
okay for anyone that uh maybe
didn't quite keep track of this game it
was a nice London
opening
H5 yeah not the most useful
move if anything there's Knight H5 maybe
to try and get rid of the
bishop but then going forward from
here yeah this is the first tactic of
the game Knight takes F7 very typical
London tactic this happens most often
when The Bishop's not defended on
D6
and
then yeah then I took the Knight except
it was kind of a
trade but then the maining that
happened it gradually happened well I
played this move the idea was to play
this and then try and set up takes takes
and then
Fork of course we didn't go into
that
and maybe I had a more efficient
Checkmate like I probably did like this
is almost Checkmate but Bishop
H3 and then
check I could have castled here but it's
not castling with meate CU Bishop
F1 so head just set it
up
okay that was fun